the girag and experience I know my
memory is unreliable that's what the
point I meant
that's hilarious right I know
everybody's memories unreliable people
the morph their memories to make them
more convenient for their knowledge of
the past whether it's as them as a
victim or as them as the winner or as
them as the you know I didn't get my
fair shake you know there was some
behind-the-scenes shenanigans you know
if you fucking idiot yeah reliable
terrible but they're gonna use this
machine yeah exactly they're not ready
yet but one day they will one day we'll
be able to access each other's brains
just like you we send each other photos
like if you were somewhere cool you sent
me a photo I get it on my phone we're
gonna you gonna be able to see my I'm
gonna be able to you know put public so
I want to make my on my eyesight public
because I'm at Yellowstone you know and
you go public with your vision you show
everybody else and you can put it up on
a database where people draw from
that'll be like the first step people
will share their experiences a few
people sneaking porn or them jerking off
before I impart experiences and then
it'll just go to hey I'm Carl I'm always
on this motherfuckers always on 24/7 you
can watch some shit you can watch some
jerk-off you can watching my sex and
people just start they'd only live their
life can't wait to get home with me Carl
okay wait the girls out there just do an
ecstasy in fact bitches driving the
fastest animal if Carl's channel became
public everybody would want to just be
inside frogs I yeah you'd be the
hottest-selling yeah and people would
start complaining they would say look
man nobody is living a real life anymore
everybody's living other people's lives
here's a game came up with a great
concept yeah yeah because your life is
boring as fuck but you could just be a
Carm Karl is out there ball win an
apology if Karl gets shot boom you used
to go back to regular life that's the
risk because then you'd have to find a
new channel to subscribe to all right
you know Carl's dead favorite TV shows
that yeah exactly follow Eddie calls
best friend that would be a new art form
the new art form will be living your
life in a spectacular manner to which
some people would want to actually give
up being a real person so they could be
you and
experience it directly and you will
become a million people they see through
you we're not exactly sure they're not
the influence Carl we think that Carl is
acting independently but it is possible
if you think about it that all those
Minds linked up together could form one
unique and universal direction in which
Carl might want to go well that's kind
of like Instagram right now that's
bananas but you're talking about I'm
taking the next level son because if
Carl realizes he gets a lot of views
what he's doing he's gonna threesomes
yeah
then he's gonna do more threesome of
course and if he gets a lot of views
when he realizes that he's on a plane or
a jacuzzi oh just up he's gonna like
that look when a guy gets recognized for
being a big fat guy and like gets famous
for being a fat guy if you ever seen one
of those guys talk to their agents and
the agents will tell you I've seen it
happen with my own eyes don't lose
weight man if you lose weigh you're
gonna lose rolls right why is that
because because they've locked on to the
idea of you as the fat guy right they
just decide they decide let's just kill
just keep this going
don't fuck this up if you will in a
literal way we train people yeah they
just keep eating so they'll stay fat and
funny if you told the fat guy like they
do people love eating and if you just I
just need you to just go fucking crazy
if you just eat a lot bro all day people
gonna just be you it's a lot of fat
people
there's skinny in real life but they
could live like a fat guy through you
and we can make money I'm Skechers it's
in on this he wants this fashion show
your eating show let me get some guy who
just all day he does he drinks fucking
vodka and he eats subs just meatball
subs chicken parm all day so people
subscribe just so they can experience
what it's like to be fucked up drunk
with a chicken's agility of chicken
parmesan sambal is greasy meatballs and
sausage and pepper shit they're not
allowed to eat anymore and I will draw
it life follows drunk life follow that
and every now and then Carl go to a
massage parlor and get jerked off and
like yeah but you can't tell your wife
about that like Carl is doing some crazy
shit what's he doing here like three
sandwiches yeah you beat Carl you don't
even tell her
about car getting jerked off he's eating
a sub while he's getting jerked off the
kids a maniac that's the next level shit
man that's what's gonna happen
people are saying the kids are wasting
their lives right you just waste your
life sitting there watching TV not even
out there doing anything well that's
just TV right TV is like the smoke
signals of entertainment I mean it's
beautiful for us but so was a smoke
signal when you didn't know where the
fuck the camp was where is everybody
these two older fucker I can find them
that's a lifesaver especially when it's
cold out that shit was a lifesaver right
that's the what TV is is the smoke
signals of digital entertainment one day
you're gonna actually be that you're
gonna be in that guy's head sorry's
starting already slowly with reality
shows and all that stuff yeah we're all
gonna be one everybody got Facebook
everybody got instagram everybody's on
something you can you can you you know
you just can't stream it the way you're
talking about it you know that's coming
that's gonna happen it's gonna be weird
as fuck
[Music]
[Applause]